you know you're kind of matching our mic
flag to me oh yeah you're right that's
like an off-yellow this is like a person
almost well who are you wearing I mean
from a sweater earlier to a suit right
now making it oh gee Vashti suit I think
there's no way to say that about
sounding like a but you are I mean do
you know not true
you love it though I have fun with it
that's true yeah yeah well I mean our
your co-star she's a Chanel girl who's a
bigger fashionista you or her maybe guy
look at his LV trip tonight and all blue
he's looking good yeah so you recognize
him without the bolt cutter first time I
just did a dingo thing okay what was it
like to live life with that bowl cut
Timothy it's behind she was a tree no no
it's not so silly cuz it's your hair and
that's it no one no one cares so you
know yeah in life when you learn that
lesson I think you're self-conscious
about really self-conscious about me
know when you're rocking a bowl Cup for
the first time yeah absolutely but uh
then you realize nobody cares but I
definitely have like more cats than
usual in that period
I'm career skyrocketing right now what
can we expect switching gears a little
bit for little women because we are so
excited for that one it's it's uh it's
similar to the king okay it's it's
wildly different and it's in an awesome
movie Greta is gonna be here tonight
actually yeah and and it's a great movie
I'm really proud of it I haven't seen it
yet so speaking at a term but I'm really
really feeling
good about it and what a joy I got to be
with Saoirse and Greta again except this
time I wasn't on a it wasn't in a tiny
house in California and I was a penis I
got to play like a great we're in the
great literary parts in American and by
the way fans going nuts for you and
searches chemistry together they seen it
all right well in the trailer on the
trailer yeah absolutely I was like wait
who they cited - yeah yeah no but I
appreciate you saying that I mean your
career eat Joel was talking about this
earlier he's like even since we made
this movie your career is just
skyrocketing like on another level its
life crazy for you like you paparazzi
falling around all the time and stuff
now how are you handling all that you
know enough particularly I mean I feel
like even when I was growing up like I
don't know there's ways to meet it
halfway and I've way rather these kinds
of stresses or anxieties than like what
am I gonna get on my ph SAT or SAT or
ATT or whatever I guess I'm not
isolating what
what's the College equivalent of that
like a bar or something like be a lawyer
but I feel like the paps are following
you it's not now I don't feel like it
works that way anymore as much I mean
those things exist but there's a bigger
conversation but it's social media you
know anyway anybody has a camera
anywhere so I wonder what the business
model is following people around a DSLR
but uh
[Music]